foreign
[Music]
I lost my parents
that pain
[Music]
made me who I am
it's been a lifetime trying to right the
wrongs of the past
as if fighting crime would bring my
parents back
you actually did it
I can't imagine what you've been through
I love you monkey you lost both parents
in one day
I went back in time to save my parents
instead
I completely broke the universe
if you went back and changed the past
this world must die
the future
you know what the symbol stands for
means hope right
I will help you fight that
you want to get nuts
let's get nuts
I have to undo what I did
these scars we have
make us who we are I'm about to go back
and fix them
no Mr tragedy to find you
thank you no matter what we do
We're not gonna be able to fix this no
nobody died
[Music]
you're strapped to your parachutes Hey
where's yours
foreign
I love you too so how was it this week
how's school Google was good
oh
this is mad trippy dude this is
catastrophic
this world must die
I'm not gonna lose there again
foreign
let's get nuts
we're in unguarded territory
we try not to die
are you ready ready let's go
[Music]
we have fancy friends
yo who's the new bird
exact
tell me something
you can go anywhere
[Music]
another timeline
Another Universe
so why do you want to stay and fight to
save this one
this is the world where my mom lives
I'm not gonna lose her again
[Music]
time has a pattern
that it can't help reliving
different people different worlds
drawn to each other with
magnets
[Music]
it's my face so my face
if you were to go into the past
you have no idea what the consequences
can be Bruce I could fix things you
could also destroy everything
completely broke the universe
besides we've been waiting for you
created a world with no metahumans
and now there's no one to defend us
want some help
[Music]
you're
you are yeah
I'm Batman
[Music]
if I can't undo what I did
if I can't get back
there might not be a future
what's the plate Batman what do we do we
try not to die
it's not Clark
Miss Cara
foreign
Barry what are you doing our kids are
gonna want to see this
[Music]
tell me something
you can go anywhere you want right
any timeline
and the universe
[Music]
why do you want to stay
it's like to take this one
you change the future
and you changed the path
are you in
foreign
[Music]